Jocko is a nickname right but it's a
nickname I've had ever since I was born
what I think that did influence is that
when I would meet this is back in the
70s man there was no weird names
everyone has a weird name now right so
back in the day when I was going into
you know first grade second grade
kindergarten you go out on the
schoolyard whatever you're meeting Bill
you're meeting Frank you're meeting
David and then there's this freaking kid
whose name is Jocko which is which is a
totally different type of name at a very
young age I had to be able to negotiate
a little bit of awkwardness and maybe a
little bit of teasing or maybe a little
bit I had to learn to negotiate that at
a young age yeah oh you know oh my name
is Jaco what kind of name is that it's a
dumb one you know but that's what my
parents get whatever like the little
things so I think that that like the
same as having the name Echo kind of you
have to you have to learn how to
negotiate having a strange name that you
actually have to explain yeah